hello and welcome to this video yeah
Burt and played him so much recently I
mean not as much as it happens usually
what is he going for yeah I'm going for
the brea now and see what he comes up
with so with d3 know it was my main line
stuff Oh was that a mistake probably not
a mistake but maybe a bit early okay um
yeah I feel that I'm kind of belongs
into the position and I'm going to
fianchetto shouldn't be wrong an
interesting we knew when this kind of
position is Bishop g7 now i have 8 36
and then um then d5 if you get it done
yes but i think this should be possible
not to have h 9 36 don't mind the trade
that much i believe but I'm not yet a
big expert on the brayer rly just
experimenting a little bit
uh-huh okay
you why not
how to play here interesting very
complex um pawn structure there in the
center 97-95 looks right but possible
night and i don't i'm not sure about
this not f5 can can be an issue maybe
yeah yeah this is what i'm talking about
i'm not knowing this kind of middle game
so well
yeah so some night f5 coming I really
wonder this okay he releases attention
what's surprising hmm i wonder if c5 is
a move here d 5 does not work but maybe
i can go up the entire 58 doesn't make
any sense if i go c 5 later i'm not sure
if it is a good movie 5 d 5 9 f8 hmm I
mean it cannot be terribly bad but I'm
still not sure maybe after d file i can
actually okay it's doing this
interesting I can go King takes a night
at five and I don't think so
anyway I have to speed up here I think
maybe it's not a big difference how I
take yeah yeah I have an idea phage I
don't don't think that this is this is a
big issue ok but what now c4 or not ok
let's go see for anyway I'm taking too
long him really I'm taking too long
still have that nagging feeling that
some kind of 95 could be an issue or
night f5 for that matter hmm okay Queen
doesn't have so many squares here
I wonder if I can somehow we use his
Luke's position yet it's a very loose
position maybe this wow I didn't even
consider that move Wow okay now maybe it
is good i mean i'm not saying it is bad
it's just that I've never considered it
Wow okay hmm I had definitely is
dangerous that's absolutely clear time
morning let's prevent their five him
not ideal but had to had to make a
decision I think after taking on a five
is better but it's not taking their okay
gee I should be okay on night to e6 and
so on coming yeah I'm fine I'm really
fine I think nice is playing super
ambitiously super risk early and not
very good but I let's see what happens i
know that kind of game always playing
sharp stuff it shouldn't work but then
I'm blundering something okay check
that's why this totally falling apart if
either sorry gone like resigns yeah
early resigned we could try stuff when I
it's lost yeah but I've got this coming
up this is the worst part night-night
come night coming here well okay as a
tough game and I was I was under some
pressure here this is a kind of typical
brea position but probably not um play
to the best buy me I thought he just
goes d5 he end is slightly better that
was my my take on the position why does
slightly better to do to space and dumb
yeah that's not a good piece it looks
manageable yeah it's not like black
erson is this terrible him but why
definitely has some edge yeah this now
I'm blocking everything I was expecting
d5 starboard okay and it's not an
essential move yeah this is very
ambitious as usual and hear that that
was shocking to me I was really thinking
he had to take with the rook but yeah my
idea was to play d5 and this is also
what the engine gives with equal play no
no this is an idea I would Knight g4 is
coming whoops so this is the move and
then 96mm I understand that you wanted
to avoid that here I was thinking he
just takes what was the problem with
this I didn't see the issue therefore
might have felt that this is a unclear
position and this sir I believe should
be good for black yeah the position now
is rather close this is blunted it
cannot push the five and I have easy
ideas here yeah it's minus 1.5 black
wins hmm and take stakes yeah i was
thinking DTX so Darryl and Queenie seven
it's it's it's full of holes one point
was that greenish for is pretty strong
now attacking here and pinning it was
just play to make it make it easier
check I'm just just taking everything
now and I'm winning mmm yeah i was i'm
always fearing some kind of swindle by
him because it's such a good tactical
player always getting dynamic things
going well i often have strategically
winning position because you just place
a very risky stuff and I always fear
that there's some kind of spill not
coming okay well thanks for watching